[Música]
el mar
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias por invitarme
creo que todo hemos estado muchas veces
en estas presentaciones y muchas veces
hemos hablado de valparaíso de valpo de
su pasado glorioso que todo esperamos
que se reactiva alguna vez es cierto y
yo diría en este pasado glorioso al
paraíso que suele asociarse a postales o
imágenes tiene que ver con esto con el
arte con el patrimonio con la herencia
esta ciudad rica de inmigrantes
liberales que de alguna manera en
clavaron a cabo un centro de
emprendimiento tiene que ver también con
su loca geografía su anfiteatro y todas
las canciones ya hay en una situación
más podemos decir más dramática gitano
rodríguez insano y toda la bohemia que
terminado en algunos casos en vandalismo
y éste valparaíso siempre se ha pensado
que en la base del futuro desarrollo la
ciudad y lo que amar hoy día que eso no
es así y hace rato que no es así hace
rato que la ciudad está viviendo de su
glorias pasadas sin plata además cierto
con una mochila de piedras que es que la
unesco lo declaró patrimonio humanidad
pero le da un peso para mantenerlo y esa
mochila de piedra ha hecho quienes
tenemos todo el tiempo esperando cómo
vamos a hacer una nueva venecia y como
la gente es a dar cuenta por fin que
valparaíso es ese tesoro oculto que
algunos no quieren ver pero todo cambia
y grieta que un fenómeno
más allá de la unión que lo voy a tener
de ella y por qué ser una niña de bien
notar lo que ha hecho lo que hace grieta
es un bonito cultural es un momento de
transición y el expositor anterior habla
de esta pesadilla que tenemos siempre de
que el mundo se va a acabar con el botón
con cantar a los prisioneros el dedo el
miedo al dedo que apretar el botón con
los robots antes había las pestes que
iban a matar a toda europa de este única
y siempre hemos tenido la sensación de
que el mundo se va acabar y lo que dice
creyentes que eso está en curso
y
hay imágenes que los recrean película
2012 y una serie de cuentos y alertas
bastante aterradoras lo que viene
imágenes también muy conmovedoras como
estos osos polares pingüinos y diversas
fauna tiene digamos que aparecen en
situaciones bastante dramáticas como
aquellos aves es cierto que están
muriendo en petróleo o los pingüinos que
se empiezan a caer al agua por el
glaciar se van derritiendo y toda esta
situación que uno lo ve como verdad un
cataclismo un cataclismo inminente y el
santiago esto se hace mucho más sentido
porque ante una ciudad que está
contaminada está una foto que muestra la
contaminación en todo con uno escucha
greta del cataclismo y ver oso polar
cayéndose el agua porque se derriten los
glaciares inmediatamente esta imagen y
después de la sequía como que todo
cuadra digamos de que obviamente lo que
viene muy complejo
creo que no se va a acabar el mundo y la
tecnología ha demostrado que es capaz de
afrontar estos desafíos por tanto pero
lo que sí va a pasar es que las ciudades
van a tener que cambiar que la
planificación va a tener que cambiar que
las costumbres van a tener que cambiar y
la amenaza del cataclismo es el futuro
del gran valparaíso y porque el futuro
de anv el paraíso porque lo que tiene
valparaíso de futuro y ya no de pasado
ya no de sus glorias pasadas ya no de su
anfiteatro ya no de su patrimonio en
ruinas es justamente atributos que la
transforman en un área metropolitana
de reserva natural para enfrentar o para
abordar las grandes complejidades que el
cambio climático tienen las fotos que
les voy a mostrar ahora son difíciles de
contextualizar la disfrutan al paraíso
pero están dentro del gran valparaíso
cuando uno llega a valparaíso lo primero
que ve después del valle de casablanca
que ocurre aviso a las masas de bosque a
los paisajistas no les gustan porque son
eucalipto y pino pero son bosque al
final lo que piensa los paisajes está
bueno está muy respetable la gente ve
bosques y el efecto que tienen los
bosques y está estudiado más allá que
sean pino eucalipto es que capturan co2
por tanto nosotros tenemos una ciudad
que tiene una masa de bosque gigantesca
gigantesca y entremedio tienen algunas
tranques tiene caídas de agua estos
paisajes que uno creería que están en el
suelo están en el área metropolitana
valparaíso bastante ocultos pero ocultos
con una masa de bosques en un país que
hoy día se pone como desafío producto el
cambio climático plantar 18 millones de
árboles o sea el desafío que tenemos
nosotros hoy día como países ciudades es
plantar muchos árboles 4 problema notar
árboles que se demoran en crecer y otras
cositas chicas y a los 20 años tú puedes
ver un bosque y bueno en eso tenemos
bosques consolidados
miles de hectáreas en esta ciudad
tenemos además esto acantilado que yo
uno pensaría que están en nueva zelandia
nocivo en o en la carretera austral son
los acantilados de del santuario
esférico santamaría que está cerca de la
una verde luego hace que no tienen
acceso pero que no tengan acceso un tema
de tiempo
y lo que definitivamente está la
diferencia el mar porque el mar
no solo es un paisaje sino que es la
forma en que van a resolver no solo el
problema de la sequía porque lo que
hemos visto
producto del cambio climático producto
de la falta de agua es que va a ser un
desafío para tener que transformar las
aguas y van a haber dos aguas que se van
a transformar la primera van a ser el
agua crisis hervida que se van a tratar
pero la segunda el agua de mar que se va
desalinizar como se hace ya en el norte
en antofagasta la gente toma agua de mar
desalinizada las minerías también hacen
lo mismo hay algunos problemas
ambientales y de costo pero en 20 años
cuando tengamos la amenaza que cree está
anticipa le aseguro que todos los costos
energía van a bajar entonces que vamos a
tener el gran valparaíso grandes
centrales de de estabilización de agua
que van a empujar el agua potable hacia
donde hacia el gran valparaíso hacia
calera hacia santiago
pero además
el área metropolitana tiene siempre ha
tenido su borde costero ese es lo ha
dicho mucha gente el verdadero activo
que la ciudad tiene como paisaje
y porque el perdedor activo que tiene
como que tú cuando llegas de santiago lo
primero que haces y sientes cuando
cruzas los valles de casablanca porque
es un aire de centro
es una temperatura distinta de 45 grados
piensen ustedes el escenario el cambio
climático cuánto va a valer el término
económico bajar 8 grados en 100
kilómetros de distancia del valle
central al borde costero bajar 8 grados
tiene una ciudad templada una ciudad sin
el calor agobiante sin la contaminación
de santiago entonces lo que yo quiero
decir es el punto de esta charla es que
el gran tesoro de valparaíso ya no es su
patrimonio físico no es su anfiteatro ni
su puerto ni sus universidades sin por
supuesto desmerecer el aporte que pueden
hacer el gran patrimonio tampoco se lo k
que grafía con graffiti a tracasa
colgando nada de eso
el gran tesoro que tiene el paraíso es
su paisaje y su clima en un contexto de
cambio climático donde los bosques el
agua la temperatura la belleza el
paisaje van a ser elementos que van a
subir enormemente de valor y que van a
tener una implicancia económica para la
ciudad que ya se está viendo hoy día
lo que muestra esta gráfica es eso
básicamente cierto el puerto costero de
30 kilómetros y yo los tiernos de bambú
o hasta santo domingo los bosques de
placilla los bosques de laguna verde los
bosques de la campana áreas
metropolitanas media entremedio los
bosques pero esto tiene valor en la
medida que está
al lado de una ciudad contaminada al
lado de una ciudad
a hogares muy y al lado una ciudad que
créanme siente el discurso de grieta
mucho más fuerza en ningún lugar por la
contaminación por la falta de
ventilación y el hecho que estas dos
ciudades estén al lado lo que nos hace
pensar nosotros en diez años más es que
van a ser una sola ciudad no porque se
vayan a juntar físicamente
sino porque la conectividad de los
proyectos que vienes y los proyectos que
tenemos que construir incluido un borde
costero extenso con espacios públicos
sistemas de conectividad plantas de
desalinización que inyectan agua los
bosques y a los parques va a ser el gran
atractor que va a tener santiago para
vivir para recrearse como ya lo es hoy
día que es parte importante de la
economía de la ciudad a futuro lo va a
hacer mucho más porque que lo que van a
hacer estas obras de infraestructura ya
que mucho las carreteras principales
ni siquiera utilizando en el tren que
más futurista pese a ser tren esto se va
a consolidar lo que van a permitir en la
práctica y acá lo que hice fue juntar
los mapas por la velocidad está en un
área metropolitana de 9 millones de
habitantes insertan casi 12 mil
hectáreas de bosques con tanques con un
borde costero de 20 kilómetros y ese
la forma en que nosotros aprovechemos
ese paisaje va a ser la base de no solo
la calidad de vida de la gente en al
paraíso sino que también la base de su
desarrollo económico
quiero concluir en el fondo quiero creo
que el cambio climático es una realidad
no creo los pronósticos catastrofistas
creo que la humanidad ha demostrado que
es capaz de afrontarlo desde las pestes
hasta situaciones mucho más compleja
pero lo que sí creo es que como eso lo
vamos a lograr hacer el gran valparaíso
puede ser lugar donde todas las
actividades de transformación
tecnológica se concentren
el cambio climático entonces va a
levantar una enorme cantidad de valor
asociada al paisaje un valor que hoy a
nosotros nos vemos pero que tenemos que
cuidar en los bosques en la campana en
los esteros en los tranques en la
ventilación
la oportunidad que tenemos entonces es
pensar hoy en día qué obras qué
proyectos tenemos que hacer para que
esos potenciales de clima se puedan
abrir los acantilados de laguna verde no
tienen acceso y vida el camino costero
llega sola mirasol algarrobo no llega
hasta digamos valparaíso por la
pendiente hay un montón de playas que
todavía están exploradas hay bosques en
placilla y curauma que sólo se han
desarrollado como viviendas talando
muchas veces pero no se han abierto como
espacios de recreación para una tía mary
culta de 9 millones de habitantes este
nuevo tesoro requiere grandes proyectos
para concretarlo
y a modo de conclusión solo decir que
esta mirada que le estoy prestando día
yo requiere también de parte de toda la
élite porteña de las universidades de
los centros de pensamiento como este
lugar puede empujar en conjunto esos
proyectos porque lo que sí está claro en
el cambio climático es que no tienen que
hacer transformaciones importantes no
sólo en nuestras formas de vida no sólo
dejar el auto en la casa no es sólo
contaminar o reciclar menos tenemos que
construir grandes obras que permitan
acercar este paisaje y sacarle todo el
valor económico porque ese es el futuro
que tiene esta ciudad y ya no su
patrimonio histórico su herencia y su
pasado glorioso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]